foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
three
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
check mic check mic check mic check
good evening
good afternoon good morning
wherever you may be in the world
how's everybody doing this this it's a
wonderful evening for me
wonderful evening for me
yeah don't worry elwin I'm gonna set the
stage don't worry
because I know everybody wants to talk
about it we'll we'll set the stage
how's everybody doing tonight
all right hold on I need I need I need
to
I need not feeling this music here
[Music]
oh no we don't I don't want words
[Music]
I'm trying out some new uh music because
I was using spotify before supposed to
be copyright free but then it gets like
to the end of a playlist and it starts
playing
something else that it shouldn't be
so we just can't like we can't take
chances anymore
it's okay like it's not a big deal you
don't get it just demonetizes your video
and then you have to go and edit it out
so L when getting us started with the
five gifted memberships
let's go thank you oh and I don't know
why like I keep I keep fixing this and
then it keeps messing up it works like
on the actual members but on the gift
the pop-up doesn't work
thank you so much Elwyn appreciate the
five gifteds and let's see who got those
five gifteds Lauren D King of the North
Neil Harrison Gigi is a lobster and then
chose
UC
I never know how to pronounce that name
and I'm sure you tell me I'm sure you've
told me so many times in the chat and I
just keep missing it I'm sure you've
told me so many times
[Music]
how are you welcome
him Gryffindor so those of you who just
got oh my gosh are my batteries already
out of them
oh this is a bad sign man
had this on very much but you have two
ways of powering it you can plug it into
the wall or you can do batteries and so
I've been doing batteries just to avoid
having the cord
man it's already went out
all right though to the new members of
house track and tour welcome
thank you so much for being here you
know what I'm just gonna keep it right
here for the moment because I see we got
five more gifteds from our buddy Reva
called Tyrell we got Jagged wizard Cindy
Tommy Jack Attack and Nathan I think I
recognize I recognize all of those names
I believe
so welcome my friends
you're now officially a member of House
rack and tour
guys if you are new here thank you so
much for being here and hanging out we
do a weekly Tuesday stream we call it
retro record Tour live we talk all
things Hogwarts Legacy except
for the s word the spoilers
we're gonna touch on it here at the
beginning and then we're then we're
gonna then we're gonna lock it down from
there
uh so let's see then we also got Jacob
renewing the membership Jacob thank you
so much my friend Jacob 33 film guy
welcome to all the new house wrecking
tour members and the old house recent
tour members so uh whenever you're a
member here Channel member you get
access to all the emotes which I know
you know what I'm checking it right now
I'm checking it right now how many more
slots have we unlocked because you guys
have been gifting like crazy lately I
know we have unlocked more oh my gosh
like literally
this is how careful you guys have to be
now with spoilers literally it's it's in
a thumbnail on a very large YouTuber's
Channel
I I just literally on my home page saw
what I think is a fairly
I mean not significant not like Snape
kills Dumbledore but you know stuff that
people may not want to know all right
let's see here let's see let's see
membership levels customize default
perks
all right Emoji how many do we have
we have unlocked
uh let's see it says 19 but then how
many do I have in nice right now
I thought it would show me right there
okay wait one two we can add two more
we've unlocked two more slots so I gotta
get I gotta get to work on those
but thank you guys so much for being
here man I mean we are officially in the
end game so let's get the spoiler
conversation out of the way now to make
it easier for the mods we've got a uh
question right now the poll up have you
looked at the Hogwarts I can see art
book leak so just like purely from a
news perspective
there are leaks guys official
official leaks the art book is 100
confirmed that is leaked that is legit
so if you do not want to know anything
um
it's time to be extra extra cautious
online like I kid you not I literally on
a YouTube homepage
just a video recommended to me popped up
had a spoiler an image from the art book
right right in the thumbnail so we're
not going to be doing that on our
Channel you're not going to be seeing
any um if I do if I do a video it's
definitely not going to be in the uh
thumbnail and it'll be structured the
same way I did the trophies when the
trophies leaked so what I did is I like
explained the news just so people are
caught up on the news and then we move
into the spoiler section here tonight
we're not going to get into any of the
spoilers there are also some other
reports that I'm not even going to
comment on what they are because I'm
pretty sure they're fake I was talking
to people yesterday uh and I'm pretty
sure the other stuff is fake
but yeah there's been a lot most of most
of the legit stuff is coming from the
art book there have been some other
things also that people are claiming
there's like already people with copies
of the game that I don't buy
um and I talked to a couple people
yesterday
that kind of confirmed that for me so
I don't think that stuff is even legit
anyway so just for the sake of keeping
it easy on the mods and everybody here
guys this the Harry Potter fandom has
been
resistant to spoilers for many years
many years like we have those who have
been around for a while like we had to
avoid these things like crazy back in
the day uh I mean when they would
literally ship the books in the boxes
that are like do not open until this
exact date
so we're not going to be discussing them
here on the live stream so
um if if you want to discuss them though
and I know some people love spoilers
like personally I've read all of them
I've looked at all of them I've looked
at everything
so if you want to discuss it we have a
place for you guys it's in the Discord
exclamation point Discord
there's a section there in the Discord
not anywhere just don't like start
posting like crazy but I get some people
like discussing them so we want to have
a place for you
um but also don't feel bad if if you get
timed out by the mods or if you get have
a comment hidden it's like no hard
feelings we're just trying to protect
everybody right now because we're in the
end game we're in the end game guys
January 17th
insane right insane how close we are at
this point
so exclamation point Discord if you guys
want to discuss them there
um but here on the live stream we won't
be discussing them so yes there are
leaks they're out in the wild some are
legit some aren't
from this point forward We're not gonna
be talking about them much at all so if
you see your comment disappear mods mods
are on the lookout we're being overly
cautious because I mean when we say
people have been looking forward to this
game for 20 years
that's not an exaggeration
maturation so some people are very
sensitive to spoilers and don't want to
know like anything so what is considered
a spoiler you might ask if it hasn't
been officially said by avalanche on
their official Twitter tweeted by
Chandler wood posted on hogwartsexy.com
and the FAQ the WB game support Twitter
account official sources those those are
what we're talking about here anything
else
um we're not we're not going to be
discussing so like the r book yeah
that's that's legit it comes directly
from them but it's not meant to be out
in the wild yet
so just wanted to get that out of the
way here at the beginning if you guys
are wondering why we don't talk about it
much so and again if somebody comes in
and they don't know don't don't get mad
at people mods will hide them they'll
hide the comment and it'll all be good
we'll all be good we'll explain
exclamation point spoilers in the chat
that'll that'll kind of explain to
people in a quick way why we're doing it
this way
uh and let's see we're already getting
some super chats hold up hold up hold up
okay Mike subscribe to the channel
welcome Mike thank you cheesy pasta
gaming what a great name cheesy pasta
gaming thank you for being here and
subscribing and then we have a super
chat from Marines and mammals been
re-watching Fantastic Beasts and I'm
wondering what is your favorite magical
creature I mean I'm always like my wand
core on Wizarding World it's Phoenix I
know Phoenix is Phoenix a cliche answer
I feel like it's kind of a cliche answer
I'm like your produce I'm your grip I'm
Gryffindor I'm gonna play on the good
side you know Phoenix is my favorite
creature so yeah I just I love the idea
of rebirth Resurrection like what the
Phoenix represents you know new life
I always have dude I always have and
yeah the fact that it's also my One Core
it just works Marines and mammals thank
you so much for your Super Chat though
very much appreciated uh sir Thompson
also subscribed to the channel Jack
subscribe to the channel psycho with a
two dollar Super Chat psycho welcome
back my friend do I think eight
gigabytes of RAM will work in my opinion
uh I think hold on they officially uh
first of all I'm not the one to ask I
know moderators here Nico and I'm pretty
sure elwin's PC as well and we might
have some others who are PC they might
be better to ask on like the technical
side of things
where did it go I know they posted about
this okay yeah here it is so the minimum
all right let me make sure I'm not
showing a spoiler
okay we're good we're good
all right I'm gonna turn down the music
just a bit now it's kind of loud in my
ear
all right so here's the minimum specs
they're recommending right here so yeah
they do recommend 16 gigs that's
interesting
recommend 16 gigs for minimum oh yeah so
I don't know psycho that's a good
question
that is a good question
I mean I would say oh wow because
they're talking right here they're
saying that this would be 720 30 FPS low
quality settings wow that's 16 gigs of
RAM oh I mean it might be rough I have
no idea
I would say if you don't hit the minimum
though it may struggle to be able to oh
wow that's just 7 20 30 FPS too oh my
gosh
but then also probably depends on your
other parts in your computer as well
right like your GPU
but yeah so those are the ones that I
know they changed them a couple times
that was what they officially said this
past week Ryan with a membership as well
Ryan welcome to house wreck and tour you
are now officially officially a member
of House wreck and tour thank you for
being here enjoy your emoji you get
discounted merch as well special role in
the Discord uh and then we also have
nerdy giant with a super chat
nerdy giant I look forward to waking up
every morning to see what new info on
Hogwarts we've gotten it's been daily it
has
I think it will continue to be daily too
yeah I mean that's I kind of joke in the
beginning like saying we're in the end
game now but I mean we are guys
everybody's like this month's gonna drag
by
what maybe it's because I'm trying to
pump out the content and keep everybody
up to date but I feel like it's flying
by I mean the 17th already
and their marketing has been great I've
loved you know the marketing early on
very early on there was that that really
rough period when they didn't say much
at all about the game right it was very
quiet
and we just didn't know what was
happening but now Chandler Eric those
guys have been doing a great job I love
the the bus things I don't know if you
guys have seen the buses in the UK I
think that's great yeah I I definitely
feel like they're gonna do even little
things daily right
so like we've been getting these
character card reveals we're gonna talk
about some of that tonight
don't think Chandler will sleep I know
right Cindy like when Chandler said he
had a tweet a few probably a week or so
ago saying like
this month's gonna drag by for people or
something and I was like not you
Chandler not you this month is Gonna Fly
by you're gonna snap your fingers it's
gonna be done AJ draws with a super chat
as well what is up AJ my wand is or your
wand wood is bow truckle
three-inch house elf hair core Patronus
is a
oh my goodness you had me for a second
there AJ you had me for a second
bootstruckle is that even a I don't
think that's a thing but
house elf Air corps Patronus is a
Magikarp oh my gosh what's up AJ good to
see you here man AJ draws everybody if
you haven't checked out AJ on Twitter I
think that's you probably have an
Instagram too right AJ but AJ does some
awesome Wizarding World artwork I'm
trying to say I need to say hello to
everyone but we keep getting uh let's
see we've got Matthew with a sub fat man
on ice with a sub the Cavs with a sub
and then psycho with another Super Chat
still deployed so it's either try with
my tiny personal laptop or go Dart till
the end of March until I get to my
actual setup oh man
tiny personal laptop oh
well if you're gonna be playing on PC
anyway
like when you get back psycho you might
as well try it right and then if it
doesn't work it doesn't work like well
I'll have to I'll have to wait till I'm
back
I hope it works for you though dude I
hope it works
yeah I like I'm just I'm totally
ignorant on
I mean I know a little bit about PC
specs and all that but I don't know that
I've ever seen one
like minimum 16.
that feels crazy to me but then for the
uh
like for the ultra or Ultra 4K they're
recommended 32 gigs of RAM I just
upgraded my PC a few years ago to 32
because I had 16 for a while volte as
well volte what is up my friend with a
super chat retro same we've been stuck
at work since nine this morning
currently 8 16.
save me from this nightmare oh my
goodness how much longer do you have
volte been at work since nine it's
currently 8 16 it's almost 12 hours you
got like a 12 hour shift
[Music]
all right so again I'm gonna have to be
I feel like we're gonna have to be extra
I'm gonna just black out the screen for
a second
extra cautious of spoilers across the
board now I feel like
[Music]
because I kid you not guys I literally
just my YouTube homepage a second ago
all right don't worry about this one
this one's good I wanted to talk about
this for a second but before we do that
you know what before we do that we
forgot
we forgot Morgan Mayhem though with the
Super Chat as well Morgan thank you so
much for your support I feel like I got
my letter after waiting over two decades
finally going to get to go home man if
you guys haven't seen Morgan the uh the
Potter collector who is
long been a staple in the Harry Potter
Community covering Wizarding World but
he's not a gamer and so he has been kind
of a Loosely following Hogwarts Legacy
he just did a reaction video to the
first showcase and I think he has one
coming on the second showcase
but just seeing the joy and excitement
from fans who have been waiting for this
game for a long time and haven't like
followed it as close as we have I mean
we've been falling every single little
detail you know
but seeing that man his excitement it's
contagious it's contagious
so I'm glad to hear your excitement as
well Morgan Luke with a super chat too
do you think wands will have different
styles and colors the trailers that do
show one seem to showcase the same one
style we know we know we're at least
gonna have the styles that are on the
Wizarding World site because we can
bring those over
it's gonna it's gonna import that from
your Wizarding World profile if you link
it up so I think at the very least
you've got you know you've got those and
I still do like I think there's going to
be some sort of one customization I
don't know what it is I don't know how
deep it's going to be but if you think
about the showcases particularly with
the brooms and with the clothing of the
character they really focus on like the
Cosmetic side of it like you can look
like whatever you want to look like and
still keep your favorite properties like
the Buffs and stuff that you want on
your gear
so I'm hoping that they'll do the same
with wands like but again it's also such
a small thing like how are you are you
even gonna see it that much in gameplay
but I I mean to me I've never cared
about it as much as everyone else
but I agree Luke that is by far a huge
request among fans even if it's
something simple like I don't know you
get like some sort of little ring that
you can put around or you get like a
jewel or maybe it's like a Malfoy style
thing
or I don't know Voldemort you get a
skull or something on there
volte with another Super Chat be here
till eight in the morning
sir
right so yeah volte is uh in the
military guys
might not make it back soldiers just
know I love you guys oh volte don't say
that dude you're gonna come back man
you're gonna come back
and you're gonna get to enjoy Hogwarts
Legacy in all of its Glory my friend in
all of its Glory hopefully on a nice uh
a nice PC when you get back home dude
and then James but volte seriously dude
thank you for your service as always and
your continued support here on the
channel my friend very much appreciated
and then James Prince with a super chat
as well retro have you ever spoken about
the girl in the background of the
trailers
the class is wearing a Blazer and pants
oh that's a very specific question James
we probably have it's not ringing a bell
though
you're not in the military vaulty what
I thought you said that before
there's somebody there's somebody that
talks about being in the military
you're a game developer though what wait
do you work for Avalanche volte
well you know what volte thank you for
your service on games my friend
the tables have turd
right
oh my goodness
I don't I don't even know what to
believe with volte anymore I don't know
what to believe
you're a game developer and your working
tool
wait don't don't say who you work for do
not say that will be an article tomorrow
if you say your hours are you got in at
nine this morning
and then you're there till eight in the
morning what
what
don't do not say so you'll say oh and
then you said you said deployed
right does it deploy me military
oh my goodness well and then you said
you might not come back alive bolti
don't do this to me man don't don't toss
me around like this
come on now
as he chat as he gives another Super
Chat volte thank you so much for your
support regardless of where you're at
whatever you're doing volte I I hope
it's for the good of mankind
and I wish you well my friend I wish you
well
that is a interesting turn indeed Chad
James I don't know though if you uh I'm
trying to think of a specific the girl
in the background of the trailer yeah
I'm gonna need to know which which
trailer specifically
all right well we have a quick break
from the chat
well we have a darn it volte
darn it balsy
all right hold on we're switching it
anyway we're switching it we'll be right
back guys we'll be back we'll be back
multi with the super jet again
try not to get the game delayed okay
dude that's some insane crunch right
there
insane crunch again
I would recommend not saying who you
work for
oh my gosh
that's crazy though dude for real that's
that's some crazy hours my wife's in the
medical field and doesn't even
have to do those kinds of hours
all right so let's shout out to people
in the chat James thank you again for
the Super Chat we will get to it here
momentarily but who all do we have here
hanging tonight oh my goodness okay
hacked house
packed house tonight let's see who's
here hanging out in the chat though all
right we got ether here we got AJ draws
both members of house track and tour
Andrew Hill Arc fort's awful awful
Artful I remember that name Blue Moon
Brittany L regulars right there and
channel members Captain classy
Christopher Slater Cindy W and Clint
both members of house tracking tour
right there and then chose UC here as
well another Channel member Cody cygnus
jabberwock
another another name I recognize thank
you for being here seeing this member of
House tracking tour as well de grimly
Dan B dark a33 a33 one in
David what is up David darklord Aeron I
just saw you drop in dark lord Aeron
welcome dark lord Aeron and David
members of house tracking tour we got
Deke Squad in the house as well devrel
devil Blom Draco Dustin Quest L one oh
my goodness the the back to back to back
to back to back
house tracking tour members right there
Emily Kelly as well guys the Beard's
getting it's getting like really thick I
don't know if you can tell with my
lighting but it's just it's just a
constant habit now I'm just constantly
like
I have to stop
Emily Kelly and Eric here fetch Quest
gaming fueled by the fire Gabe Gigi as a
lobster members of house tracking tour
right there hafid Mohammed Hannah
Hufflepuff squid those two right there
channel members Huffy yuppie
Immortal YT Insight invisible Guardian
James prince Jasmine a
then we got Jason Hodges Jason Ingram
Jeremiah Robinson Casey Lawrence four
members of house tracking tour right
there killer bee Storm King of the North
I can't not see your name and say it
like that
King of the North
member of House Dragon tour as well and
Christy Jean just joined in as well
Christy welcome another member of House
wrecking tour and moderator here on the
stream last of my kin Gemini King Lauren
D Channel member there legendary gamer
Society Levi Gustafson then we got Logan
Luna Comics marvolo Ravenclaw all three
members of house wrecking tour there we
got Mathis we got new store what's up
new store then we got Michael Sullivan
Moon Lily Morgan from old oak
house tracking to our members right
there noob in the house as well what is
up noob
Noob how you feeling man you staying
hydrated you staying hydrated tonight
Noob I got a full can right here of
uh I think it's I think it's black
cherry Waterloo tonight
unopened I'm ready to go I'm ready for
the hydrates Nabil uh naguro Ravenclaw
House wrecking to remember Nat Knight
Nathan Fox another house Dragon to
remember Neath Nathan Robinson Nico the
real life Chief warlock welcome Nico
everybody knows Nico moderator here as
well Neil Harrison Nikki 25 all three
channel members right there noisy boy
panda plays games pineapple Sam
Professor Baxter oopsie here I go again
just like absent-mindedly radio Morales
and I think I said Professor Baxter
members of house track and tour Rhett
Mitchell obscurious conspiracy theorist
Riley Beatty or Beatty Ryan Hylian
Soldier 64 Ryan Melvin those are members
of house wrecking tour there Samuel
Biggs Shadow guided Sharon Cruz shax or
Shaw XOXO three members of house Dragon
tour there Stephen Birchfield supernidge
Susie Q
two members of house Dragon tour there
Taki takibana and then Tater Channel
member the crazy197 the white wolf Trent
another Channel member oh my gosh
there's so many of you in here tonight
Tyler Colley Valerian Sith Lord okay we
made it to the v's Valyrian Sith Lord
member of House Dragon tour uh Vil cry
volte wubby zodiac
zutara babe zero nine four members of
house Dragon tour there Eva or Ava maybe
and magical Jerry Sharma ravacclaw
guys thank you so much for being here
hanging out tonight uh we got a lot to
talk about dude a lot to talk about so
we stream every Tuesday and talk
Hogwarts Legacy
and then last Wednesday there was just a
huge information dump not dump
just a huge information uh reveal
release whatever you want to call it
right
all the voice actor stuff came out
and then we've been getting these steady
little drops it's awesome dude it's
awesome all right so we had let's see
let's go back to James's last Super Chat
though I told James we get back to it
and let's go ahead and switch our scenes
back over as well
all right so we got let's see what did
James say here James with another Super
Chat hey retro oh wait I read that one I
read that one and then James with
another one rewatched all the trailers
and noticed a girl in some of the
classes not wearing a robe she has a bun
in her hair never seen anyone talking
about her oh is she like the one at the
teachers
desk
the like the flying what we think is the
flying professor
oh
the other one I can think of is doesn't
the girl have the bun in the scene where
she get in the wand
I think
trying to remember
I'm trying to remember that one James
but yeah it's like it's not ringing a
bell off the top of my head
volte with another Super Chat
much love bro haha don't plan on telling
anyone who I work for don't want my
emails to be flooded the next day I know
right
right
volte as always though my friend thank
you for the support
the girl in the background uh AJ with
another Super Chat the girl in the
background isn't wearing robes because
she's a ghost murder
my goodness that win that guy dark AJ
she's a ghost murdered by Poppy and the
girl's second floor bathroom in her
first year are you kidding me
I think Poppy's in the clear guys I do I
think Poppy's in the clear Poppy's in
the clear
retro raconteur
quote it
quote it
that's not a leak that's no inside
information actually I don't know dude I
just feel like to be I feel like they're
being honest I feel like they're being
honest about Poppy
and honestly I feel like they're being
honest about fig now too we'll talk
about fig here in a second
I do though uh Christy with a super chat
as well Christy thank you so much
Christy says just stopping by to say hi
Al celebrating a work promotion yo let's
go Christy congratulations
Christy with a work promotion Let's see
we need a um
trying to think do we have any like
celebratory Emoji what would be our most
celebratory emoji
I mean maybe if you got like a raise we
could do like the niffler with the coins
going everywhere right
oh or maybe it's not a raise maybe it's
just like a better job and you're gonna
be happier sometimes it doesn't always
have to be about the money you know
but congrats Christy Matthew van over
with a super chat as well what's up
Matthew van over guys Matthew vanover
Matthew van over and I close friend of
mine we go way back high school buddy
um shout out to my friend Matthew though
Matt thanks for being here dude
appreciate the Super Chat and then we
had uh hello Jake subscribe to the
channel thank you hello Jake Dustin our
boy Dustin Quist with a super chat volte
volition he works for volition gears
trying to piece together now wait who
does volte work for
dude there is somebody here that has
donated before maybe it's always been
volte and I've just always assumed volte
was military because volte said deployed
and I just totally misread or
misunderstood
I mean isn't I don't know maybe it's a
cult like uh cultural thing like here in
the us when we say deployed it usually
means that's like a military thing
James Prince with another Super Chat
James I'm so sorry you have to keep soup
you don't have to keep super chatting
dude I'll try to catch your comment if
you uh are following up but thank you
very much I appreciate your support and
the super chats there herbology class in
reveal okay herbology class Hufflepuff
common room in the behind the scenes
video next to the owl
huh interesting so are you like what are
you thinking James don't you don't have
to Super Chat again I'll try to catch it
in the chat but what do you what do you
think in there is there are you like
do you have like a hunch about who it
could be possibly
and then we had Corey scuttles for
renewing their Channel One membership
Corey welcome to house Dragon tour my
friend you were officially
by by Thor's hammer you were deemed part
of house Trek into her right now guys
Nico in the uh we have like a moderator
Channel and Discord
and Nico's found like some sort of AI
it's above my head but we've been like
generating like profile pictures and
stuff using this
and so for those of you who aren't
regulars we had somebody a few weeks
back come in and say that they always
refer to me as retro raccoon because
it's like Raconteurs too long like what
is it what is a rack into her anyway so
I was like dude when we figured out that
we want to call our members we want to
call our community here house wrecking
tour I was like we gotta have a Sigil
you know we got to have a seal something
and our our mascots it's going to be the
raccoon
so Nico and I were playing with this AI
generator trying to get like a uh a
channel house sigil for a house Recon
tour that shows the raccoon and like a
seal oh we got some pretty good ones I
think I saw wizard PhD in the chat
Lynette what is up
I'm still mad at Jenny by the way
Lynette so we we did a live stream a few
days ago guys we streamed some Harry
Potter and Goblet of Fire beat the game
by the way believe it or not we made it
through it not a good game one of the
worst Potter games
um it has its moments it has its moments
but rougher on the edges uh so you can
find that here on YouTube the live
stream is up for that the full let's
play it was only three parts so it is a
it is a very short game but we rated
Lynette at the end of that
Jenny here I don't know if Jenny's here
tonight but Jenny ruined the surprise we
were gonna raid Lynette and we didn't
want her to know it's gonna be a
surprise and Jenny's like oh by the way
Retro's about to raise you
Jenny if you're here I'm just kidding
it's all it's all in good fun but no uh
you guys probably already know wizard
PhD but if you don't check out her
Channel she's got a lot of awesome
Hogwarts Legacy videos a lot of Hogwarts
Legacy Theory videos and I saw Lynette I
saw that your um that most recent one is
like your most viewed video I so wanted
to post in the comments because I can't
I remember commenting on that video and
I wanted to tell you I was like this is
gonna be your biggest viewed video
I just I had a hunch
I had a hunch the editing in that one
was like so good
I mean Lynette's editing it's always
good but like I just that one was like
it's like that extra touch that extra
touch
it was so good oh I see Jenny Jenny I'm
sorry it's all good Jenny it was all in
good fun
all in good fun and then we had Let's
see we got Corey or division another
fellow Hogwarts Legacy content creator
in the house with a super chat as well
hello all just recovered from a nasty
flu but now ready for lots of hyper sexy
content right recovery was spent
watching her HP classic Let's Plays nice
dude
thank you thank you for checking those
out yeah it's like it's kind of like the
small But Mighty group that watched the
Let's Plays it's a lot of very
passionate people here who love watching
the let's plays
so yeah we gotta keep we gotta see how
many we can get through before the
release of Hogwarts Legacy so we're
through the first four guys all those
are on the the channel here
um but then we started Order of the
Phoenix over on uh twitch the other day
I'll eventually bring that over to
YouTube as well but it's like you gotta
sort through copyright issues at this
point it's kind of annoying Lynette
knows what I'm talking about because
once you hit a certain point well
actually I think once we get to
Order of the Phoenix you can't turn off
the music you also couldn't turn off the
music and Goblet of Fire so it's just
like it auto detects the YouTube uh
music just Auto detects the copyright
then you can't monetize it but yeah so
we're working through that Sean thank
you for subscribing to the channel same
for unyielding Warrior as well
oh my goodness Catch My Breath
you gotta go Levi no way dude
you're a wizard Harry
you're a wizard Harry and a thumping
good night presume
all right guys
how many let me move this over here
no wait that's the wrong one I can close
that one out I'm just being like extra
cautious tonight of not spoiling people
because
it just freaked me out earlier we saw
that spoiler right on the front of
YouTube but luckily I didn't have the
screen showing so you guys didn't see it
oh my goodness we're already 176 likes
are you kidding me let's go
guys make sure to like the video if
you're having a good time here you join
this conversation it's going to help it
spread on YouTube help more people find
it and we also do some pretty cool
things so when we hit 100 likes we do a
random bit of Harry Potter quote trivia
so I owe you guys that now before the
end of the stream we'll pull a random
quote from the Harry Potter series
and you guys try to guess both the
character in the book and then when we
hit 200 because I know we're gonna hit
it we're on our way we're about to hit
it
we will do a Harry Potter
um
impression that you guys get to pick
which by the way you're getting double
tonight because I just did I just did a
Hagrid for you and I think we did
multiple last week see this chat just
gets me like so excited and they just
keep throwing out ideas by the way I
hope Elwyn wasn't too mad at me I know
someone shared the clip with the Discord
but Elwyn has been asking every week she
had to leave the stream early last week
she's been asking every week for
Bellatrix
and somebody donated right at the end it
was like Bellatrix I was like oh my
goodness they super chatted it I have to
do it I'm so sorry Owen but here we go
so hopefully they shared the clip with
you Draco yes dude like
a major YouTuber with
a lot of subscribers it was just like in
a thumbnail so it was on my home page
thumbnail from the art book boom right
there on the front page yeah
yeah I mean it's not like a mate like me
personally
I take it I take it you get I'll take it
throw it all at me I tweeted out the GIF
I'm like Jon Snow you know staring down
the oncoming horde of enemies like all
the spoilers I will do my best to Shield
you guys because I know I know Lynette
doesn't want any spoilers I'm pretty
sure Jane doesn't want any spoilers I
saw nightly nerd posting they don't want
any spoilers
um
I think the majority of uh
Hogwarts people covering this game are
like no spoilers
I'm like guys I will shield you send
them to me it's all good
at least the thumbnail's not I know it
was just like right in the thumbnail
dude right in the thumbnail some of the
some of the artwork
which that I mean this is not a spoiler
to say that art book is gonna be fire
you guys fire
fire it looks so good I mean that's even
from the publicly released preview that
um the website sci-fi did if you guys
didn't see this so this was an
officially released thing sci-fi showed
a few pictures of it looks so good looks
so good
I'm a Gryffindor right just indeed
indeed send it my way
send it all my way
you only got to switch JG
well I mean
at least it's not like a lot of people
were thinking it may not even release
till the end of the year so you don't
have as long as some people thought you
know so that's a good sign
but guys I mean it's like we're
officially we're in the home stretch we
are in the home stretch
so
as we get into the news here and talk
about we're gonna I'm gonna back up
a lot of this is sort of old news at
this point because it happened the day
after last week's stream so we're just
gonna kind of skim through this quickly
but we got a lot of big reveals
a lot of big reveals
first of all Simon Pegg man
Simon Pegg Phineas nigella's black
confirmed Headmaster they released a
whole little video on it good stuff
you're a wizard Harry great actor
obviously a huge yet I mean this is like
it's a big time actor being in this in a
video game
which he if you watch his little
interview it sounds like he was he was
kind of disappointed that he'd never
been in a uh anything Potter related
before so this is a chance
and from hearing the way that he
described Phineas
it sounds like they've nailed it dude
he's almost a cross between oh man I saw
it on Twitter somebody absolutely nailed
it
it was like um
he's gonna be a cross between
like he's a little bit of an uh
I mean he's got some very controversial
views
it's pretty much on Salazar slytherin's
side of the whole blood statist debate
then he also just straight
like he
existing for Prestige he's just there
for a check you know
he's there for the check and he's there
for the prestige it brings as being the
Headmaster of Hogwarts so this dude is
like I don't get that he I think Simon
actually talks about how he is even
going to
um like be kind of a roadblock for the
player which I don't know if that means
like actually in gameplay or if there's
something he's gonna do in the story
where he's gonna actually affect it
somehow
but Phineas we thought for a while it
was probably going to be him as the
Headmaster confirmed here we also get
the actor confirmed
I I was like oh man what a fun
announcement that's so cool and then
they're like well not so fast
not so fast they tweeted out his
character card here don't be deceived by
his surgically manicured beard
all right let's read it here Phineas
nigellous black who to this day Remains
the least popular so Sirius was right
that wasn't just serious being like sour
towards his relative
uh least popular Hogwarts Headmaster
Hogwarts has ever known makes little
effort to hide the utter disdain he has
for his students he has a cantankerous
lazy and vain pure blood with a myopic
view of the world and a condescending
and unjustifiably Superior attitude
there you go it's gonna be fun to be
around wildly ill-suited to his job his
goal is to do the least amount of work
possible
and avoid exposure to the student body
wow the just that's gonna be a stark
contrast to Dumbledore stark contrast
preferring to focus on his status in The
Wizarding World and his surgically
manicured beard so he's a little bit
vain you know being uh all concerned
with his appearance
so for a lot of professors we can see a
clear comparison to the characters and
professors we know from Harry Potter's
day I mean sharp obviously is is drawing
a lot of comparisons to Snape
but also a little bit of I feel like
Sharp's got a little bit of Moody in him
as well like Mad Eye Moody
and then we have
um like Sprout obviously is very fitting
for
oh my goodness what's her name
Mirabelle garlic so there's like a lot
of these comparisons we got the Weasley
confirmation which we're about to get to
here
obviously giving McGonagall Vibes but
then we get black who should who
couldn't be more different from
Dumbledore right
so he has officially confirmed as the
Headmaster
all right they were gonna go and then we
got so some other uh voice announcements
as well Sebastian Croft voice of the
playable character
voice one right here
and then we have Amelia gething voice of
playable character voice two she had a
really funny post on Instagram talking
about how she had to voice these uh
like for ways that the character will
die one of them's like by dragon fire
and then the other one's falling off a
broom
so a lot of people were like can we fall
off a broom confirmed apparently by the
voice actors here
I think we can say you can fall off the
broom
and apparently die from it apparently
die from it and now I know a lot of
people asking well what does that mean
if you fall over the water right what if
you fall over the water
I don't know I don't know
but we will see right we will see and
then it was just I mean they just kept
this was all in one day by the way this
was January 11th so I mean like Simon
Peg alone that could have been the day's
announcement you know
that could have been the day the whole
day and they're like no we're just gonna
give you the full cast pretty much
just gonna give you the full cast Leslie
nickel I think saw you say our last name
Professor Matilda Weasley
if you've watched Downton Abbey you will
recognize her
um
I watched Downton Abbey for like the
first
I probably more than have and then
there's something that happens
no spoilers there's something that
happens that just really made me annoyed
and angry and I couldn't I couldn't bear
to watch the rest
so I stopped watching but it's a good
show it's a good show she plays um oh my
gosh what's her name
what is her name
in the in the Downton Abbey show Mrs Pat
Moore
this is Pat Moore that's her name
so good in the Show Downton Abbey
and I think she's gonna be great for
Weasley Matilda Weasley so we got her
name as well
oh yeah Simon Pegg he's like Simon Peg's
got a lot of uh yeah there we go Miss
patmore yep David David got it
David got it go back and watch again
should I should I go back Ravenclaw
Tyrell and watch it all the way through
and with a super chat
Odin oh my goodness we've got Odin
himself in the chat
I feel like I have to just hold this up
for you I feel like I have to hold it up
for you me and your siblings can't wait
to play that we wonder
um can we choose to be left-handed in
the character customization a few games
let us be that even in role-playing
games Hufflepuff by the way nice dude
hey thanks so much for the Super Chat
Okay so
my hunch is no Odin my hunch is no I'm
so sorry to disappoint you I could be
wrong
so it's it's for sure not in the
character select screen because we have
seen that I think in full in the first
gameplay showcase
so the gameplay showcase our buddy
expect to go he got to create his own
character there he goes to the full
character creator menu and so I
immediately saw that thought oh man so
it's not in
but then somebody else pointed out you
know what it could be
it could be when you get your wand
so I'm holding out hope it is POS
possibly when you get your wand they
like ask you what is your wand hand
maybe I mean that like I'm volte I think
volte had to leave apparently volte's a
game designer I don't know if we have
any game designers here hanging out
like to me in my mind it's like how hard
is it right you just flip you know just
flip everything
but it like there's some weird things
with like the way games work then you
like have to flip the whole world or
something the example I always give it
was such a big deal when
um
was it Skyward Sword or Twilight
Princess for the Zelda game I think it
was Twilight Princess first
so Twilight Princess came out on the
GameCube
in the GameCube version link is
Left-Handed as he is always
traditionally been left-handed but in
the Wii version they made him
right-handed because most people are
right-handed so when you're holding the
Wii remote in your right hand it just
felt more natural to see it but when
they did that it wasn't just a simple
swap of Link like me as a person who's
never done any video game development
would think oh we'll just I mean put it
in the other hand right no it's like the
whole world was flipped everything was
mirrored
so I I hope for you guys I hope for all
the lefties out there I hope there is a
way but my guess is no my guess is no
and also because we haven't seen it we
haven't seen it in any of the footage
that we've seen and we've seen a lot of
footage at this point
we've seen a lot of footage but it could
just be like the jump thing you know
like I kept saying I don't think you can
jump because it's such like a basic
thing why wouldn't they have shown that
right why wouldn't they have shown that
and then they finally just like yeah you
could jump
so maybe they're just one day gonna be
like oh left-handed yeah here you go he
was in there all along
it'd be great but it would have to it
would affect the camera work and stuff
for sure because you notice right now it
the way the camera is it's kind of
positioned like our character slightly
off center do you see a lot of games
doing this nowadays
um even The Witcher did this in their
update The Witcher actually has where
you can go back and forth you can switch
to the traditional camera view where
it's like that third person not quite
like sort of behind the back view that
we traditionally associate then you have
games like the newer God of War where it
sort of it makes it a more cinematic
feel the characters just slightly off
center and so you're sort of looking
like just off their right shoulder so
when they're aiming it all lines up
nicely
but all that would have to flip too
all that would have to flip yo wait did
I see nightly nerd in the house as well
for real dude yes trying to avoid all
the police is like playing 5v1 dodgeball
for real dude I was telling them earlier
I will be I've I think I've read pretty
much every spoiler so I will be the
defender of the Hogwarts Legacy crew
I know you don't want to know I don't
think James wants to know I don't think
wizard PhD wants to know I don't know
about uh let's see podcast now Andy
Hogwarts Legacy explained scrub work all
those guys and gals I don't know if
anybody else I for the most part though
I think I've seen everybody saying like
they don't want to know anything
send them to me
and I'll I'll do I'll do what we need to
do guys I'll protect you I will protect
you
Dan oh wait dan b game designer okay
let's see if Dan had any response on
this
it was Twilight Princess Gabe says same
thing with Laura Croft used to be
left-handed now she's right-handed okay
Dan okay Dan Dan says tricky for
cutscenes where the character holds the
wand imagine having to change the one
hand for every cutscene oh so you'd have
to have like double cut scenes
interesting
Professor Baxter be back in a bit sounds
good
let's see if Dan said anything else or
if we had any other uh game devs or
anything
yeah no spoilers here veal cry
exclamation point spoilers in the chat
guys
oh yeah let's look at the poll I
probably should take that down now Ellen
that might help you guys too
might help people not want to talk about
them as much
all right so let me go here okay so we
asked a question to start off the stream
864 votes by the way thank you guys if
you voted in the poll have you looked at
the Hogwarts Legacy art book leak
65 said no 35 said yes so that that
pretty much lines up with what I was
expecting
pretty much lines up but yeah no no
spoiler discussions here guys other than
just like as a generic news item of yeah
they're out there they're happening
if you want to avoid it be very careful
mods here are going to be hiding in the
comments as they see them come in
and again if you post one and if you
just dropping in and you accidentally
ask something it's it's fine you know as
long as you're not being malicious about
it if you are
the mods have have the permission to use
the Thor's hammer okay
also known as the band Hammer which we
hope we don't have to use
but for the innocent people just
dropping and being like yo did you see
this in the art book
slow down we know you didn't mean
anything by it
but we're gonna have to hide the comment
and then just ask you everyone here is
trying to go in without knowing
I have seen it yes uh let's see we also
had fueled by the fire oh wait hold on
hold on we missed Henry K Henry K dude
I'm so sorry four minutes ago I'm
slacking
Henry K with a super chat says I wonder
if the magical Hogwarts map would be
made in this game no so the creators of
that were which you've if you've seen
the movies then they didn't do a great
job of showing this but it's a moony
wormtail padfoot and prongs also known
as
the Marauders so that's Harry's dad
James that's Sirius Black that's
wormtail AKA Peter Pettigrew and then
Remus lupine
so they are the ones who came up with
that map so that's going to be much
later
much later for that
but they we've already seen I mean
there's going to be a map in the game
so I think that might be a little bit of
a uh
you know a thing where yeah maybe
there's no lore in place for it just yet
although we've seen like the ministry is
heavily involved in our character
so maybe they don't quite give us a
Marauders map type thing but maybe it's
something that's included in the field
guide if they want to try and explain it
story-wise which they really don't need
to but I know how they've been so
attentive to all the details with the
lore and such they may actually try and
explain it with the story so if they do
I think that's how they would do it it's
like using that Ministry angle on it
imagine if Charles Dance voiced the main
villain oh my gosh fueled by the fire
you'd be so good
which have they said
I don't think they've said anything
about ran rock or Rookwood yet have they
I don't think they've said that
uh the r book cygnus I think is
releasing like a week
after the game
yeah so it's really unfortunate that it
leaked because I remember Chandler
posting it was either about the art book
or the um the strategy guide Chandler
posting about hey this is intentional
we're releasing it after the launch of
the game because we want it all to be
fresh for you guys so I don't think they
won at the art book out there I don't
but it makes sense if you've already got
companies like um I'm not saying it's
sci-fi who leaked it but sci-fi did a
big story on it
where they clearly had seen some of the
artwork so you assume maybe the art book
is out in the wild now maybe people are
shipping it early who knows
uh let's see then we had battle beast
and Riley V2 thank you for subscribing
guys I haven't even I don't think I've
stopped talking this whole time
we're gonna stop and hydrate for one
moment
as we look here at Asif Ali who plays
Amit the car
somebody in YouTube comments was like
it's not the car
I was like wait a second I know that's
not it but it does it does sound like
when you say the car the car it does
sound like the car the car
the car
so this one was weird because at first
it said a different character and they
had a completely different picture
so I don't know if he voiced both of
them or if they just made a mistake I
saw a correction on it later
but I can't remember who tweeted the
correction if it was Chandler if it was
the WB Games account but I'm pretty sure
I saw a correction somewhere
maybe waiting for a bunch of the voice
actor reveals until launch yeah true
City they might keep some of them under
wraps although they had a big one like
Charles Dance I think they would want to
go and reveal that one
uh Candace Kane as professor onai
so confirm we knew that was natsai's
Mother we weren't 100 sure on the last
name but now confirmation yes professor
onai
and then we had this one here
some kapila professor
satyavati Shah
probably butchering that name my
apologies if so and then yo what about
this one don't you love this one man
Luke Youngblood of Harry Potter Fame if
you guys recognize him Lee Jordan from
the films and then we also had AJ draws
with a super chat meant to say let's
support the devs and ignore the haters
this keyboard sucks
hey all good AJ and I think I saw two
for chess from AJ
AJ thank you so much for your support as
always
and then Tristan with another Super Chat
do you think we'll be able to rescue a
dragon and maybe ride them and really
hoping we can ride them
I mean I think so for sure on the rescue
of Dragon part I think from the
cutscenes we've seen especially that
scene where we've got like the player
character and Poppy and then like the
Dragon
and then if you look at the scene like
one of the early early scenes where I
went and slowed this down
in the reveal trailer you can see that
that Dragon the hybridium black dragon
is in some sort of Cavern
and it's he is like chained down at the
front
and you have to freeze at just the right
moment but if you get it at the right
frame you'll see he like breaks free
from these chains so yeah and then
riding I hope so
I hope so
that'd be so cool
that one obviously we don't we don't
have as much to go on to say whether or
not but I mean you've got the mounts in
the game right you've got dragons in the
game come on come on WB make it happen
now I could also see how that would be
something very challenging from a
from a design perspective
but but they do already have program I
mean they've got the flight programmed
in right you could do hippogriff you can
you could fly on the brooms so they've
got different styles of flying just be a
much larger animal that you're flying
right
but Tristan thank you so much for the
Super Chat very much appreciated
yeah the young quiddish announcer right
what a great last name yo Nick Shaw this
is my favorite hey I wonder why dude I
wonder why
so Luke plays a character by the name of
Everett Clapton a Ravenclaw that we see
in the defense against the dark arts
classroom scene kind of in the
background we see this character here
and then we had Jason Anthony who plays
both nearly headless Nick and the
Sorting Hat
and then we had our PC specs which you
talked about earlier and then here now
we're getting to the good ones all right
these three I feel like this is what
we're going to talk about most tonight
Draco dude the three months time flies
always better when you're around great
people Draco
thank you for the three months my friend
for continuing to be part
of our house here
part of house record tour
and you're right man it does fly like
this making this whole Channel and
devoting so much of it to Hogwarts
Legacy it really has made it Go by a lot
faster for me I gotta say
I gotta say it has
and then hold on do we have another okay
just making sure I didn't miss anything
need time to go faster
Morty what is up dude whoa wait is that
I I think that's my buddy Morty from uh
I think I used to play Destiny is that
the same Morty
is that the same Morty if it is dude
well regardless but if it is you Morty
shout out dude thank you for thank you
for stopping by man yeah it's been uh
it's been a fun ride and if you're a new
Morty and you like have no idea who I am
until this evening thank you for being
here too my friend we can get to know
each other hang out it's a cool place a
lot of fun people here
a lot of fun people
all right so I think this is where we're
gonna spend
a lot of our discussion
so we got Matilda Weasley here
we knew we expected this one we the
Autodesk session we were able to kind of
piece it together ladies and gentlemen
our first confirmed Gryffindor Professor
let's go where my gryffindor's at in the
chat if you're a channel member you got
access to the O's emotes let's see the
gryffindors
where the gryffindor's at I feel like
she runs Hogwarts I I agree I agree she
is running things because Phineas is
just like straight up not doing anything
that dude doesn't even care he could not
care less about what's going on
nice Morty thanks dude
there we go there's all the gryffindors
in the chat and then we got a dream and
plays games with a super chat maybe the
dragon is tied to the story The Way We
are used in Skyrim like connect so James
has been kind of
expecto go our buddy James has been on
that theory for a while thinking that
that dragon is like Merlin's dragon or
something the hybridium black that we
can't keep seeing very possible
very possible
and uh Jenna Lee Turner welcome to house
tracking tour thank you so much for
choosing to become a member here enjoy
your emoji discount and merch special
role in the Discord
Neil said can't recall from gameplay
while riding a hippogriff we have to
worry about avoiding trees because of
the Wings
I don't think they really showed it kind
of crashing
but given what the voice actress said I
I think so
or are people gonna be attacking us
while we're flying right
so immediate McGonagall Vibes right
Transfiguration Deputy head mistress
she's clearly knows what's going on
she's the one who gives us the field
guide
sort of our introduction to Hogwarts
um maybe a little bit warmer than
McGonagall but they changed her attire
which I thought this this new attire
that they put her in this one to me
looks way more mcgonical whereas the
other one looked way more Weasley
that one was more kind of like a warm
Vibe whereas this one is more like she
is like professional on her game you
know
both both good I like the way they both
look but it's interesting right like how
decisions like that get made
this late you know
all right so then we get to her bio here
we go Matilda Weasley is an
exceptionally talented witch with a
background as a curse breaker for the
ministry
dude
the ministry in this game has their eyes
all over Hogwarts for some reason
their fingerprints are all over Hogwarts
multiple characters have
worked for the ministry
the ministry gives us the field guide
what's up Katrina welcome yeah JG she is
indeed a Gryffindor she's got the little
icon right here at the top
so she's known for her composure an
extraordinary wand work so see what I
mean like well put together she's like
she knows
very professional she is a firm but fair
Transfiguration professor and a slightly
intimidating well-respected Deputy head
Mr C before I wasn't getting much of the
intimidated vibes from her I I wasn't
McGonagall like you know right away like
McGonagall she's going to be fair
she's legit but you better not cross her
you better not cross mcgonal I wasn't
getting that much from Weasley at the
beginning but it seems like now like
maybe that's the reason for this sort of
uh like changing the attire a little bit
I don't know
legendary gamer Society with a super
chat remember we were told a Weasley or
two
exactly birthday is Friday gonna hit up
the Hogwarts Legacy merch oh did
Chandler respond
did he respond on the merge question
all right pause pause pause
we're opening a new window because again
you got to be extra safe with the
spoilers
we're safe with the spoilers right now
or you might be talking about something
different
all right let me pull up my tweet so
yeah there's been a lot of merch popping
up
oh no he didn't respond to this one
might be talking about a different tweet
or did he like
oh he retweeted it let's go so Chandler
said
oh this is like right when we went live
darn it Chandler I just missed it
all right so yeah I had been seeing some
people that sent this to me
uh I don't know about territories and
all that I'll post the link on Twitter
later for people but there's been a lot
of Hogwarts Legacy merch that people
have been sending me showing up on
Amazon so I sent in a screenshot
to the WB game support and Chandler and
so Chandler just says here I've gotten a
few DMS and tags about this and yes
can't confirm these products are
officially licensed
let's go dude thank you Chandler good to
get confirmation on that
so yeah they got a lot of fun stuff in
here man I'm gonna have to get one of
these hoodies for sure
I like this wand one right here
but yeah as soon as we uh Hop Off The
Stream tonight I will uh get that out
there probably Post in the description
as well later we get the little Amazon
affiliate link going if you guys use my
anything you buy on Amazon if you use
the affiliate link for it
it's actually a really cool thing where
it helps out the channel at no extra
charge to you
so I just have to make sure I disclose
when it's an affiliate link but yeah
that's awesome man that's awesome that
we got confirmation on that and thank
you for chatting that that Super Chat as
well I would have told him probably
would have missed it because I'm very
careful once I start streaming I'm like
I cannot click on notifications or
messages
especially in this uh age of spoilers
that we are in now
no products for Canada no
you know how specific merch I don't
think they had any how specific I don't
think I saw any well I mean they've
there's already so much house specific
merch anyway right for for The Wizarding
World so they probably decided they
wanted to keep it Wizarding World
Centric
or I'm sorry uh Hogwarts Legacy Centric
so it's like so it's sort of
differentiated from the overall
Wizarding World stuff because we've been
able to buy like house merch for years
you know
but yeah there's a there's a lot of
stuff in there a lot of stuff in there
all right did I miss anything else okay
check check check check I think we're
good
Elwyn I can I'll I'll send you something
Owen
I'll have to send elwin something you
got friends down here Ellen you got
friends in the US
we can help you out
all right so did we finish reading this
one no we didn't we didn't even finish
so Professor Weasley has been tasked
with getting the player up to speed in
their studies and introduces them to
their Wizards Field Guide and the rule
requirement both of which are invaluable
resources for a new fifth year with a
great deal to learn
foreign
she's strict as we just learned but also
like she clearly cares about she's going
to want us to succeed some people are
saying maybe she's the bad dude like if
they really like you really want to get
people a shot make the Weasley a baddie
that would work that
that would work even with you guys
saying it could be possible
I still look at it as like less than one
percent that's less than one percent the
Weasley Gryffindor no
she's gonna be good
she's gotta be on the good side but
if they wanted to do a crazy twist
there you go but you can't just do a
twist just for the sake of it right
hey Cindy thanks for stopping by have a
good one
I'll ship it to you exactly
send something to Libya
oh yeah Jenny is in Canada too we got a
lot of people in Canada part of the
community here
uh marvolo they have house specific
robes
I don't know if they're available in the
official Wizarding World I think they
are
I think they are in the official
Wizarding World shop I know for sure
they have them if you ever go to The
Wizarding World
they have them there to buy
yeah
oh now there you go Kelly if they
release the house fanatic robes
now that
would be that would be Hogwarts Legacy
specific you know but still oh
yeah dude those would be good
those would be good all right so there's
our breakdown of Matilda Weasley
and then honestly of all the ones we've
gotten so far this one might be the most
interesting because I didn't think this
dude was going to be that important
and maybe he's not but he is a Ministry
official
also a Hufflepuff
so we get confirmation he is a
Hufflepuff George osrick or ostrich
maybe but he appears in the very first
revealed trailer he's in the carriage
with Professor fig and our player
character
assuming they are either in route to or
from Gringos because we know about that
cutscene with ran Rock and in the in the
bank
so all that like he is our contact at
the ministry it seems it seems like he's
been tasked maybe he's even the one who
retrieves us
I thought I had a hunch early on I
several months back we said maybe he
works for the ministry
because he shows fig the newspaper about
ran Rock and the supposed rebellion and
how the ministry kind of views fig as
this sort of enigmatic guy they don't
know if he's legit or not so maybe
George is like the one guy who's
in Harry's day you know they're always a
lot of people at the ministry didn't
believe him but then he had a couple who
he could rely on so maybe George is that
guy for us
so we get a little breakdown of George
right here with his card a high-ranking
Ministry magic official George is a
Charming gregarious fellow and a
decades-long friend to both Professor
fig and his wife Miriam his uncanny
ability to unravel the most enigmatic
riddles that's like very specific right
he unravels riddles combined with his
steadfast loyalty and trustworthiness
prompted Miriam to enlist his help in
solving a seemingly indecipherable
puzzle she uncovered just before she
died more on that death in a second he
may have bitten off more than he can
chew however and will need the player's
help to pick up where Miriam left off
which to me right away says like this is
connected to the ancient Magic
not so much the Rand Rock side of things
but the ancient Magic
so he's able to crack codes riddles
Charming gregarious fellow so people are
instantly like he's a bad guy right
Tristan with another Super Chat Thank
You Tristan for your support appreciate
it if we were able to fight a boss like
a giant dragon or do you think we can
it's killed with vodka diver seems a
little so for a dragon
um spells don't work on the dragons
their hide protects them
and I think that's the case for there
might be some other magical creatures
where that's the case as well
but yeah they're definitely gonna have
to figure out the balance of Avada
Kedavra I'm not too worried about it and
I think
I think it's going to be fairly late
game when you could get it
because of what Chandler said Chandler
had a comment I can't remember if this
was a reply to somebody or what but he
talked about how it's gonna have to be
earned
it's gonna have to be earned so it's not
something that you're just gonna like
start Hogwarts and you immediately go to
the we don't even know which Quest you
get I was about to say Sebastian Quest
but we don't know for sure Sebastian we
know there's one with crucio but we
don't know about the others so it sounds
like you're not just going to be able to
walk into Hogwarts first day and be like
okay let's go learn AK
so I think it's gonna have to be it's
gonna be something that takes place
narratively later in the story and by
the time you get it
it won't be as game breaking but yeah
there's other ways they can get around
that like they can have really fast
characters that could like teleport
they're operating like you remember
Voldemort and the The Little Death Eater
after not really an apparating but that
sort of teleporting thing they would do
and then but yeah if it's like dragons
their hide would prevent them
from being uh
from being harmed by AK and there may be
other creatures like that too I can't
remember my uh
my knowledge on I haven't read through
Fantastic Beasts in a while
so yeah we shall see we shall see
foreign
yeah it does have a long timer as well
all right so that's it for this guy
again another Ministry connection though
he's actually working directly for the
ministry
all right so we're going to close this
one out and then finally we get to our
boy Ellie Azar fig
another Gryffindor
so the gryffindors we thought we were
going to be left out not so fast says
Avalanche we get Professor fig here and
then we also get Professor Weasley who's
the head of house you guys think
do you think it's a
you think it's fig or you think it's
Weasley
Eleazar fig is his name and then here's
his subject magical Theory
magical theory is that
I have not had a chance to look this up
yet
so after you guys get through telling me
whether you think it's fig or Weasley
for the uh head of house
is this something that's ever been in
the books
is this an established Canon thing I
just forgotten about
because I don't remember seeing that
maybe this is like a precursor to
ancient runes or something
everybody's saying Weasley
yeah I feel like Weasley's the odds on
favorite too for head of Gryffindor
100 Weasley it says Dustin
[Music]
typing on an iPhone 7 is poop
magical Theory podcast time oh was this
a topic over there JP
was this their topic the other day
yeah hopefully we do get a surprise
villain Professor Baxter like not just
for the sake of a Twist but oh JG thinks
it's fig
all right so Mr Moe says magical Theory
referred to the study of the nature of
magic such as studying how spells
exactly worked those who specialize in
the field were known as magical
theoreticians
as an elective okay okay
take a poll
we could do a poll Kevin and PJ welcome
thank you for subscribing or I mean you
could just look it up right
we do have the power of the internet at
our at our disposal here Hogwarts
subjects
okay so this is officially Wizarding
World from 2015.
first years at Hogwarts must take seven
subjects Transfiguration charms potions
history magic defense against dark arts
astronomy and herbology flying lessons
are also compulsory
at the end of their second year at
Hogwarts students are required to choose
a minimum of two more subjects from the
following list arithmacy muggle studies
divination study of ancient runes and
Care magical creatures see I thought
everybody was thinking to be study of
ancient runes
very specialized subjects such as
Alchemy are sometimes offered in the
final two years if there is sufficient
demand
Dylan what is up Dylan
Dylan welcome my friend hope everyone is
enjoying the stream so far don't forget
to smash the like button
as he posts the Lions there Dylan thank
you so much for the Super Chat and your
continued support of the stream here my
friend
and let's see I'm pretty sure we're I
think we're over 200 now
oh my gosh we're almost at 300 likes
guys thank you all for the likes
thank you all very much for the crazy
number of likes I owe you guys a Harry
Potter quote trivia at the end and also
a random random quote
or impression rather from the Harry
Potter series
all right what says it was mentioned in
the first film
yeah I was thinking that fig was going
to be a Ravenclaw that was gonna be my
guess for fig
this was mentioned in the first film
oh I don't remember that
magical theory is a first-year elective
class all right well let's keep reading
I don't see it here yet
a very specialized subject such as
Alchemy yeah we read that one a slightly
different list of school subjects
appeared in my earliest notes herbology
is called herbalism divination is
compulsory from the first year as our
Alchemy and a subject simply called
beasts whereas Transfiguration is called
Transfiguration slash metamorphosis okay
so this was from 2015 but regardless
I mean it's also kind of like
it's not really history magic either
it's magical Theory
all right so let's see
hold on we're not just gonna look at
those though I mean I feel like that's
the official Source right there
but I'll check one more for you I'll
check two more for you guys
I want to see what the HP lexicon says
gosh it's so bright
so bright all right let's go to the M's
yeah so they don't have it in here
either muggle studies class
all right so I bet where you guys are
getting it this is gonna be my guess I'm
guessing that HP Wiki has added it
and I'm guessing that they have added it
as a result of it appearing on this
that's usually what they do HP Wiki is
very very quick too bad stuff
There It Is Magical Theory
a subject taught to at least first years
it was taught in class 67 wait wait wait
wait wait wait
go away ads go away
I was taught in class 67 on the fourth
floor of Hogwarts Castle okay their
Source we're gonna look at the source
here presumably covered Magic from a
purely theoretical View
and magical Theory by adelbert waffling
might be a required textbook so let's
see what 43 is Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone film there you go so
that was their source
interesting so I guess it is I mean if
it appeared in the first film
obviously with that one they were being
very careful to to stay true to Canon
and all that
but yeah then they had like some like
xylem and see
ah
yeah I wonder why they went with this
instead of just doing ancient runes
though
super curious about that
not that it Matt I mean it's not like
it's it's not gonna be that much of a
difference
but so fig talks about magic from a
purely theoretical View
magical Theory by adelbert waffling
which is I'm assuming that textbook
appeared in one of the
it's used as a textbook for first year
students at Hogwarts let's see what
their sources for that one
okay so chapter five Diagon Alley in
Philosopher's Stone they talked about
this magical Theory Book
it was available at the Hogwarts Library
or for sale at florissantblot's
bookstore for two galleons
all right cool
very cool so I mean it makes sense if
fig is going to be the one like leading
us on this journey of
trying to discover and understand what
this ancient magic is
and now we get into his story which is
very
it's a tragic one
it is a tragic one
Jake what's up Jake welcome
yeah guys you can talk spoilers in the
Discord we have a special section for it
there so exclamation point Discord we're
just not discussing any of them here
just just keeping keeping it safe for
everybody
I agree some of them are moderate
and then some but honestly like there's
a there's a vastly different scale when
it comes to how people feel about
spoilers I've learned this I have
learned this
so I just err on the side of caution
yeah exclamation point Discord you can
uh there's a little section there feel
free to hop in there and talk about it
all you want
how's it going Krista
oh my goodness Love Potion what the heck
what is going on here Nico
theory is that our parents were
unspeakables that's why we are somehow
important oh so you think like they
raised us and we never even knew they
chose not to teach us magic for some
reason Maybe
maybe how's it going Crystal welcome
Johnny Blaze what's up Johnny
oh I we had a super chat from Jake too I
didn't see that one Jake dude I'm sorry
I missed it I am making a game while
watching your stream two more weeks
little birdie told me Nico is dating a
special
oh that's where that comment came from
oh really
a little birdie
I have no I have no idea what this is
about chat is this an inside joke that I
missed
oh my goodness all right let's read
about fig here
all right it gets a little sad the
magical Theory professor at Hogwarts
left behind his aspirations of working
for the ministry of magic
again another Ministry thing to follow
his wife Miriam around the world as she
researched the seeming disappearance of
ancient Magic
boom that's
I feel like that's the kickoff of the
whole story right here to be honest with
you vague eventually grew weary of this
Quest and left her to continue wait hold
on
hold on the first time I read that
I think eventually grew weary of this
Quest and left her to continue on her
own while he took on the job of magic
with you professor at Hogwarts oh
wait do you think that means that
doesn't mean they separated does it
or does it just mean like he physically
left
but like the way it says that he grew
weary
foreign
oh I don't know what whatever the case
maybe he he physically decided he did
not want to do the traveling anymore
so he took the job Hogwarts magical
Theory and then when Miriam was killed
during her travels fig felt responsible
because he was not there a guilt that
haunts him to this day
he is determined to understand why and
how she died and to finish her work fig
is a kind
when they're writing these I feel like
guys we're hitting you over the head
with this
he's actually a good dude don't
speculate and think he's the big bad
or maybe
or maybe they're just really they knew
we got it they we guessed it too quickly
no I'm kidding I I think I do think fake
is legit good at this point uh he's
determined to understand why and how she
died in to finish her work if he's a
kind knowledgeable professor and will be
one of the players greatest allies
they're like we promise he is an ally
during their time in Hogwarts with
respect to the trials they will face
both inside and outside the castle walls
outside the castle walls dude
Azkaban Azkaban maybe maybe Ministry of
magic are they gonna get mad at us too
maybe
oh dude okay let's see we had another
Super Chat from our buddy volte
what happened to my dear AK I need that
as early as possible
I just feel like it's gonna be late game
because Chandler said it has to be
earned
it has to be earned or maybe there maybe
you could all dude imagine this would be
awesome if you could actually go
and you could get it early game but it's
just like this grueling Quest you have
to do and if you try to do it from the
beginning you're just so under leveled
that you you could do it but only if
you're just like super skilled at the
game
that'd be kind of cool right if it's
like you really have to work for it or
just follow the course of the game and
Power Up level up your character
Wesley Henry Jr thank you for
subscribing to the channel and then Mr
Mo with a super chat so new fig Theory
oh here we go here we go he isn't a
villain if but he does figure out the
ministry are the ones who killed his
wife to hide what she found and then he
seeks Vengeance against the ministry oh
that's like the whole second half of the
game dude right
the Goblins join us we're all like the
Battle of Hogwarts oh my gosh the Battle
of Hogwarts at the end the Goblins are
on our side we're fighting the ministry
imagine dude imagine
okay no let me back off I think it's
gonna go that crazy but I could see I
like where your head's at there that
like what if it's the ministry that
somehow maybe she discovered something
maybe she discovered something that the
ministry did not want out there
and so they're like oh dude what if it's
this what if it's the friend
what if it's George here
Charming gregarious okay Avalanche come
on now they're not all charming and
gregarious
oh that would be crazy devrel if she was
actually still alive
I like that too
there's so many things they could do
with this
but what if so what if
all right let's think this through
he finds out that it's actually the
ministry
and then he what if he traced it back to
his friend George
oh my gosh because they did say that
like she turns to George she turns to
George for help remember
because of his uncanny ability to
unravel the most enigmatic riddles
oh my gosh that's dark dude that is dark
if that's what happened
volte with another Super Chat no I'm
crying now
don't cry volte don't cry we're just
it's just speculation we don't know for
sure
you don't know for sure yet
but thank you again for the Super Chat
Mr Moe thank you as well
can Wizards turn into dragons
honestly I don't see why a wizard
couldn't have a dragon
as a
oh wait I see where you're going I see
where you're going
I see where you're going with that
um animagus animagus however you prefer
to pronounce it
because they are a Patronus like a
dragon is a confirmed Patronus
crazy though
Miriam is an Azkaban oh
my goodness okay wait wait wait hold on
though I see why
you guys are blowing my mind here
because we somebody was just asking
earlier about the dragon we can see like
the blue flames or like on the belly the
neck area
there's something possibly ancient Magic
Miriam just so happens to be
investigating this ancient Magic
it's possible dude it's possible
foreign
coming up with the idea what if they
just oh yeah they didn't kill her but
they're just like oh you're going to
Azkaban
we can't let you ever get out to speak
of this
I really hope we go to Azkaban man it
was in the trailer please
we've already seen where they've changed
a few things already from that first
trailer
so who knows who knows the mentors on
the box though they're on the box too
okay all right we're slowly making our
way through these this is the last
character one last character reveal we
got so it's weird they didn't do like a
they didn't do a card for this one but
Professor Shaw takes her astronomy
lessons quite seriously which Professor
are you most excited to meet during your
studies at Hogwarts then you get like
the I mean she she looks pretty Stern
right there
I love that screenshot though
colors like look at the her attire
very nice very nice that gold right
there
get her house yet
feeling like a Ravenclaw
definitely going down the rabbit hole
tonight I know right that's what we
always do here
is there new here welcome this will be
what we always do chat says something
cool or crazy or off the rails and
Retro's like
dive down a rabbit hole fortunately
tonight we don't have any trailers to
break down so
past two weeks I've been like oh man
we're past like three four weeks I've
been like oh we gotta hurry and get
through this
but no tonight's all about you guys
tonight I was just uh
oh and there is one more there is one
more the uh the buses this was such a
fun marketing idea I love this they're
doing a little competition for these
as far as I know these are only in
London
so I don't think we'll get to see any of
them here in the U.S but they have five
of these different buses right here
where they have each house represented
and then one is the key art from the
game
and then they're also doing this contest
so if you guys are in the UK near the
London area folks
and you see these buses snap a photo
tweet a picture of any of our five bus
designs using hashtag Hogwarts legacybus
and mention us for the chance to win a
Hogwarts Legacy collectors edition on
PS5
you can enter up to five times with a
picture of each bus and all five buses
have officially been found yo Rossi
thank you for the tier one my friend
thank you for being a member here of
house wrecking tool
enjoy your emoji there and your discount
and merch your special Discord role
you're a wizard Harry you're a wizard
Alyssa welcome thank you for subscribing
all right again though I'm gonna go off
screen here for a second I want to pull
up the pictures of the
I just want to make sure we don't get
any spoiler
I'm gonna go to Chandler's page because
I think Chandler actually uh
been sharing these two
I okay just like my totally unbiased
opinion
so here was the first one we found
there's the Hufflepuff the huffle bus as
some have called it
first of all they're all good I love
this this is the great spectacular
marketing idea I think it's awesome
so we got that one
then Slytherin was next in line
got Slytherin right there
and we'll go up a little bit more here
the Gryffindor okay the Gryffindor one
was a
oh wait
there we go the Gryffindor was an actual
a video a little short there
so all of those uh the Little House
patches that they showed us many many
many months ago
they're kind of like the dominant piece
on there
so we got that one and then last but
certainly not least my Ravenclaw friends
I think you guys got the best one I do
just from a pure like visual now also
the person who they got really good
photos of this one too
they got some really good photos
but yeah I think I would give the
Ravenclaw when the nod as my favorite
one
the blue is gorgeous yes Moon Lily
why does it say not in service though
ravenclaws
chat Mission and Azkaban de mentors
basically become nice girl and we're a
little hobbit trying to sneak by them
if we don't learn expecto patronum
which they've confirmed it's not going
to carry over I'm still not convinced
that we won't learn it and it's just
like a non-corporeal version or it's one
that is based on our character's
backstory in the game I still think
that's possible
but if not then stealth is the only
option right unless our ancient Magic
so yeah like you have to you have to
sneak back out of Azkaban I could see it
dude I could see it but it's supposed to
be very hard to get out of right so we'd
have to have we'd have to have something
a secret sauce a special way to get in
and out
I would have to go right if I saw one of
these buses even if I wasn't going I
would just have to go ride one just to
say I I rode in the Gryffindor bus
and then the final one
is the key art one right here
which also looks really nice
happening guys like it's
officially happening guys 60 FPS uh
confirmed yes so
a 60 FPS targeted mode has been
confirmed that's the terminology they
use a lot of people were worried when
they saw that like oh my gosh that means
it doesn't run at 60 a solid 60. no I
mean do we know for sure that it's a
solid 60 FPS no but all companies say
targeted no company will say locked 60
FPS they they just they have to protect
themselves they're not going to say that
like even God of War which I think
the new uh God of War Ragnarok which
runs at above 60 FPS a lot of times on
the PS5 even they say targeting 60fps
and the fact that it has vrr support as
well
um but yeah so it is confirmed that PS5
and Xbox series X and S have a mode that
targets 60fps that is a uh the
performance mode and then there's also
Fidelity mode as well
you're not answer oh my gosh Nick oh my
gosh I can't even say that out loud to
my Ravenclaw friends
the ravenclaws will just leave the
stream right now
that that might warrant an unsub Nick if
I read that aloud
I can't do it
do it
uh there's always too many patronuses
yeah there's so many patronuses that
would have been really hard to bring
over for sure
would have been really hard to bring
that over
you won't leave retro hey thank you
Professor Baxter
you want to know your house JG
have you taken the uh Wizarding World
quiz
you should take the Wizarding World quiz
or have you taken it and you're just
still like uncertain
do I think there will be another
gameplay showcase I
no Beeman or baymen no don't leave
don't do it
another gameplay showcase
I used to think yes
now I'm leaning more towards no
but they just drop those out of nowhere
I mean the first two it was just like
what
what
just dropped out of nowhere
so I'm leaning toward no but I wouldn't
rule it out you know I mean obviously
the marketing is at kind of a fever
pitch right now it's gonna be busy busy
busy all the way up until launch
foreign all the way up until launch
VR in this game oh do you think they'll
have VR has that been confirmed or
anything
I know they confirmed the
steam deck which is nice a lot of people
have been asking about that
lots of people have been asking about
the steam deck stuff
um so I meant to talk about this in the
beginning but I totally forgot to do
this
totally forgot
so Luke Stevens a fairly large YouTuber
recently shared a video right here a
skeptic's look at Hogwarts Legacy it was
posted two weeks ago has almost half a
million views at this point but we
reacted to it here live on stream one
night and a lot of you guys also watched
Luke I know and had seen the video so we
had a really I think we had a really
good healthy discussion on hype managing
expectations looking at some of the
stuff Luke talked about and Luke was
very kind enough to he saw a part of
that live stream and he reached out and
actually asked me to do like an
interview with him so he just shared a
video today right here the Hogwarts
Legacy hype debate featuring retro
record tour so I just want to shout out
to Luke and if you guys haven't seen the
video check it out I appreciate him
inviting me and giving me the
opportunity I thought it was a really
good
healthy discussion like it's not like we
were arguing and yelling at each other
we weren't arguing yelling it was a good
discussion and he's he's clearly a
Potter fan too like he's he's a fan of
the Wizarding World and I don't think he
was hating with his initial video just
pointing out some valid
concerns and maybe some things that to
be skeptical about which is not cynical
there's a difference between skepticism
and cynicism but we had a really good
chat and so he just posted the video
today and I've already heard from some
of you in the Discord with the with very
kind words and there was a lot of
comments and feedback on the video
itself so
thank you all for everyone who checked
it out and who um enjoyed it Mr Mo that
was one of my favorite discussion videos
I've seen in a while well done thank you
dude yeah I mean I never talked to Luke
before so I didn't know I mean anytime
you meet someone for the first time it's
like you don't really know how the Vibes
are going to be but he was very laid
back and obviously you guys know from
watching me I'm laid back we keep it
pretty chill here
he is so like analytical with his videos
I mean some of his videos guys like if
you look at this uh
so this is his mostly video this has
over three million views it is a three
and a half hour
critique of the Batman Arkham series
right three million views on three and a
half hours dude so I think maybe people
who didn't know of Luke's work saw him
like critiquing a little bit and
pointing out some things maybe we should
be concerned about
and thought like oh he's just hating on
the game no I mean he like some of these
long-form videos he really gets in and
break like really breaks it down
and these are games he loves too so it's
like he talks about the pros and the
cons so I think it was coming from a
good place so I'm glad you guys uh
I'm glad those of you who've watched it
have enjoyed it you saw that before the
stream fetch Quest gaming nice yeah we
we had a good chat it was a good chat
and so yeah again I I appreciate Luke
having me on so if you guys haven't seen
it yet it's a cool video check out his
channel as well if you really enjoy like
these these deep Dives man deep dives
into games
he has a lot but then he also has like
this one's a 13 minute one right here
where he just really focuses on a
specific aspect of something in
Assassin's Creed but then he also has
like these three and a half hour like
two hours or 50 minutes here this was
almost five hours here on cyberpunk
and it all sounds like I was asking him
about his process like dude do you how
do you fully outline all of this like
how do you is it word for word
so he would share with me a little bit
about how that works because it's it's
amazing I mean the amount of time it
would take just to re I mean record
alone
it's crazy
but yeah I enjoyed uh enjoyed chatting
with him so
all right so let's see we had a
Jason gin and Lewis or Luis subscribe to
the channel thank you guys so much
welcome
Professor black video we touched on it a
little bit Christy you know we could
actually we should watch that one live
I'm gonna pull that up here that's one
more thing we can react to live
again I'm being very careful with what
we're pulling up Hogwarts or uh YouTube
wise because
I just saw a spoiler earlier on my
YouTube homepage for the art book from
it oh there it is again different
YouTuber this time
but yeah large large YouTubers appearing
on home pages so
oh my goodness where is it dude
all right I'm just gonna have to
maximize my screen here
there they are Hogwarts Legacy
foreign
yeah so we'll watch this a little bit
later
Mr Mo relates to Luke a lot honestly
he's excited am I still have another
reservation transparency from the devs
huge Comfort yeah yeah allows me to get
more excited than normal
it's JG dude I love bloodborne's one of
my favorite games of all time
I have the platinum trophy in both
bloodborne and Eldon ring Eldon Rings up
there too I don't know if I'm gonna say
favorite game one of my favorites of all
time but it's definitely up there
yeah huge fan of those games
Ravenclaw Tyrell enjoyed good criticism
don't think the video convey quite what
he was saying as intended I see yeah
well to be fair like he uh he talks
about how the vast majority of people
have been in the in the Hogwarts
Community have been very
not combative even if they disagreed
with him not combative so shout out to
all of you guys because I know a lot of
you have watched and maybe even
commented on some of those videos but
and I told him in the video I was like
yeah man I think it's a carryover from
part of it is a carryover from the
Potter fandom which was just
such a welcoming like fun fandom from
the moment it started forming so I think
part of that is it's carried over from
that and then I think the other part of
it is just like
I mean the people that are leading the
Hogwarts Legacy Community you know
people like James people like Chandler
people who are really like the voices of
this game
you know we're just uh
they try to keep it pretty chill so
yeah we just we started order the
Phoenix if you go to my twitch channel
the VOD is still up I don't have it
posted on YouTube yet but we did start
our order of the Phoenix play through
like if you just if you're itching for
it and he can't wait you can see part
one over on Twitch but I'm gonna get it
brought over to YouTube here in a few
days it just takes some time because of
the uh
copyright you gotta you gotta go back
through and check music and stuff
what do I think about the NPCs
um
I don't know what you mean think about
the NPCs
very hype with God or Ragnarok yeah I
loved Ragnarok I don't know what the
I mean I feel like the general reception
has been pretty pleased with it I loved
it quite a bit
see I'll tell like the regulars know
I'll just give you guys a little insight
of my personality like I just I enjoy
I'm an optimist I enjoy being excited
for things
but while also
am I being skeptical when I
like I'm also upfront and honest with
you guys like we've we've talked about
issues and concerns with the game though
really the whole time on my channel like
one of my first Hogwarts Legacy videos
was about concerns that I have
so I'm never going to outright I'm not
gonna
lie to people or mislead people but when
I have something I'm excited about then
yeah I will I will share
that I'm excited about it and why I'm
excited about it
oh let's see Tristan with a super chat
you're asking if it's a spoiler
um
[Music]
no not the way you
I got to be careful now how I answer it
but no I I don't think it was the way
you you worded it there yeah
so as far as like the publicly released
stuff or officially released stuff
Tristan we saw some references in the
Autodesk session to what you're asking
about
and then I don't know if you've looked
at leak stuff or not but yeah I've I've
got no idea man on how it would be
implemented
no idea but thank you for the Super Chat
and then uh gilbies with the
subscription as well thank you for
subscribing to the channel
yes Adam exactly
that's I think that's what I try to be
I try to be both excited and a realist
and here's another thing for for you
guys
when the game comes out
I am fairly confident
that I'm gonna enjoy this game
I'm fairly confident in that
even if
it has flaws
I know right a shocking statement
no game is perfect no game I mean you
think about your favorite game of all
time it's not it's not perfect
I think about some of my favorite movies
of all time there are things like ah
they could have changed that it could
have changed this I would have
personally liked this a little better
that's just like the nature of art it's
just the nature of Art
so when people critique things it
doesn't all you know it doesn't
instantly mean we hate it
and so that's why for me personally like
I don't know everybody's personality is
different too like some people just
genuinely
don't like that letdown that feeling of
disappointment of like looking forward
to something spending so much time of
their life watching YouTube videos
commenting in live streams watching
people talk about it and then being let
down which I get it I get it if you want
to optimize purely for like
just being happy and like guaranteeing
you're gonna be happy then you can have
super low expectations we were playing
Goblet of Fire the other day
uh if you want to set your expectations
there I think that's a pretty safe bet
I think it's a safe bet maybe I'm going
out on the limb there but I think it's
to say bad Hogwarts I guess he's gonna
be above that
but it's like then as long as it's
better than that you're happy right
but me like I'm just like I'm an
optimist man I I try to stay positive
while also being a realist at the same
time yeah exactly as Adam said there
321 likes yo guys thank you for all the
love at 321 likes man
that is such a huge help it helps more
people find this video Even after the
fact so even people that aren't watching
live it's gonna stay on YouTube people
might watch it tomorrow replay Squad let
me know down in the comments below if
you're watching this video later on
thank you for being here as well we
value all the people who go back and
watch on replay as well and then Bradley
with the Super Chat 20 days left excited
to see what channel does next after
launch oh Bradley man
I'm so excited dude I got some big plans
I got some big plans I want to cover a
lot more games
um more live streams for sure not live
streams like this but like gameplay
streams
but don't worry I mean for a few months
guys we're gonna hit
we're gonna hit Hogwarts Legacy pretty
hard like I want to do
I'm gonna have tip videos I'm gonna have
Secret videos I'm gonna have lore videos
all of the above dude we're gonna have
our game play like our full gameplay
we're gonna have that posted on the
channel we'll keep doing these live
streams man for as long as as long as we
still have people showing up
retro Records who are live will be a
thing
we will be a thing Tuesday evenings
we'll be here we'll sit we'll Rim if you
guys just want to literally reminisce
about Hogwarts we'll do that
but yeah it'll be interesting to see
like where especially with retro
regulator live I'm just gonna let you
guys lead me you know like where what
the audience wants to discuss and talk
about that's where we'll go we'll keep
it gaming focused and or Wizarding World
but who knows man I mean I feel like for
a good
for the first half of the year I would
say six months there's gonna I mean it's
just gonna be a lot of Hogwarts Legacy
stuff
and I want to have I want to have a
bunch of videos on the channel that are
radio Morales new to this community have
to say it rocks question second choice
for house if you do a replay though or
through dude okay hold on I wanna thank
you for being here first of all I'm glad
you enjoyed the community here I think
it's a pretty awesome group too
I think it's a pretty awesome group of
people
and enjoy hanging out and chatting every
week for sure
but oh my gosh see this is what happens
I lost it I lost where I was going
I lost it
what we were talking about we're talking
about oh yeah yeah like so I think
there's gonna be
a lot of interest in Hogwarts for
several months after launch because some
people just they don't have the money
they're gonna wait some people are gonna
be on um last gen systems so they're
gonna wait a little bit some people are
going to be playing on switch
then like holidays people are going to
be getting new systems people might be
buying the game for the first time then
you start getting into sales and
discounts at that point of the year then
maybe they I don't know early 2024
they announced some DLC a new story DLC
fingers crossed fingers crossed we'll
see Max thank you for subscribing to the
channel welcome
I am excited for the new Star Wars game
yes I want to play that but I need to
play the first one that's probably going
to be one of the first games we stream
non
Potter related
so if you guys are into that yeah the
the first one is free on Playstation
Plus right now and the second one comes
out I think it's March mid-march or
somewhere in there
so February is probably almost solely
gonna be
no dude like I don't know we don't know
no spoilers guys we don't know how much
content is in the game we don't know how
many hours it's gonna be
um
I'm hoping man I'm hoping that there are
secrets that we can just pour over for
like weeks on end trying to find like I
legit hope for that no Bradley I've
never played it and I know I would like
it I know I would just from watching
videos and stuff
um but to the question about what will
be my second house I've been trying to
decide because I feel like I'll probably
do
without giving much away about trophies
um I feel like I'll want to do a second
playthrough
even if just to play like make all the
evil choices and go fully dark
so sorry to my hufflepuffs but I'm
leaning towards either
an evil Ravenclaw or an evil
Slytherin
so first we'll be like it'll be like
based after me male Gryffindor
good making the right decisions
then second one I'll do female
right now I'm leaning towards Slytherin
but I could be persuaded for Ravenclaw
as well maybe I'll maybe I'll pick it
basically maybe I'll let you guys pick
it dude that'd be fun
maybe I will let you I will let you guys
vote
on my second playthrough it's done it's
decided that's what we're gonna do we'll
make a YouTube poll on it as after the
game is released
oh dude you guys might you guys might
persuade me to do Hufflepuff
well not persuade me I will officially
go with what you guys say it's
definitely going to be evil though
definitely going to be evil
oh yeah I'm excited for Zelda too
somebody said Zelda yeah yeah definitely
excited for Zelda and we'll probably be
covering that game some on the channel
too
evil Ravenclaw I see some evil
gryffindors
how's it going Hannah welcome
yeah Lauren I guess technically you
could but you'd have to start separate
you'd have to start separate
playthroughs so you like have to start
back from the beginning which might be
kind of weird for people Lauren was
saying how they have they've confirmed
like multiple save slots which is good
very very good
a Celebi syllabi thank you for
subscribing to the channel welcome
who wouldn't want to do an evil chaotic
Hufflepuff
either playing every house as good and
bad
ha
all right let's watch through this video
here I'm going to mute our music
so this had some cool little uh info
drops in this one
I'm playing Phineas Nigella
so this was last week I'm Simon feels
like forever ago Phineas nigellus black
Phineas black is at this point in the
story he's the Headmaster of Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft listen listen he
doesn't even try to we saw secret code
in the books and in the films he was a
portrait in um there he is Dumbledore's
office but this is at a time when he was
actually actively the Headmaster Phineas
nigellous black is the least popular
Headmaster in the history of Hogwarts
you are here to focus on your academic
Futures he is a sort of pompous
disinterested you call that a shine on
those boots
do better he's not a good teacher or or
Headmaster just straight up like he
would have done something because of the
gig you know it's a prestigious position
I don't think he has any interest in
children's education just the prestige
being in any way a role model it's not
really his concern what he wants is the
oh dude there was um of what's his name
clopton Luke Youngblood's character
being in any way she stands up right
there there he goes what he wants is the
Kudos of being the Headmaster of the
greatest Wizarding School in the world I
wonder almost daily why I accepted this
appointment from the ministry yeah he's
just a bit of an idiot really doesn't
seem ivory handled hand mirror no of
course you haven't
he is serious black Black's great great
grandfather I think I'm right in saying
that so there's got to be a little bit
of something fun in him
did you know Sirius is not the product
of the black family seemingly he's very
different and Phineas nigelis is like
the opposite of Sirius Black he's not
Noble he's not brave he's just a
self-inter trying to hate yeah
self-interested fool
I had forgotten about that in the books
when they have to hide his portrait
wait a whole game read that one again
in the Deathly Hallows book Hermione
hides the portrait of Phineas oh right
right from grimald place in her bag to
stop him leaking their location to Snape
through his portrait in Hogwarts
through the game we come across Phineas
as a sort of help and a hindrance to the
players who are working their way
through the Star Wars Harry Potter and
Star Trek your schedule will wait
indefinitely as will your student he's
entirely there to um Scupper the efforts
of the player I'm sure they're right
there any of you at the moment none like
gameplay move aside
last Slytherin the lessons I think the
Japan players will get from Phineas
nigella's black is don't be like Phineas
and I jealous black he is not someone to
Aspire to he is a nope self-involved
cantankerous slightly childish figure
and I think be less like Phineas he
seems like he enjoyed playing him though
I said I'm sure you all have plenty to
do dude look at ronenberg it was Rowan I
think rodents is like sleeping through
his talking of the game watch this I'm
sure I have plenty to do and then he
looks like oh
ronan's just totally checked out I ain't
listening to this dude
not listen to this dude
you're a wizard Harry I'm extremely
excited to be part of hey Rams welcome I
watched all those movies and also
Malcolm Williams
apart from me and so to get the role of
particular black one of the black family
that's uh that's a cool thing because
seriously yeah you could tell that
minolato in books so it feels really
good it feels like something's finally
been put right
[Music]
oh that was such a fun announcement like
out of nowhere too
which they keep telling us tip of the
iceberg you know tip of the iceberg
yeah he is dressed he is dressed very
very nicely
very nicely
all right you know what as we close out
here let's get some cozy
let's get some cozy Vibes going hold on
where are the let's go to their playlist
here
to play all
and we will Loop this
others what's up feathers welcome
oh yeah dude Ronan was just not even
Noob Ronan had no intention of uh paying
attention right there all right so I got
a little fun one here as we uh as we
wrap up I need to turn on my light for
it though
all right give the camera a second to
adjust the exposure
so we have another little fun unboxing
to do here tonight
another fun unboxing you know what we
should go full cam for this
so my mom got me this for this was a
Christmas gift
so we gotta figure out where these dudes
are gonna I might actually put them some
people noticed they they noticed that my
way bird the GameCube controller was
gone so I think we might have to place
them right here all right so it is a
magical Minis
first year set we've got it looks like
Harry Ron Hermione we got Hedwig in here
we got a letter
we got Hagrid we've got Fang and it
looks like a book and the Sorting Hat
so there's a lot in here there you can
see the little breakdown
everything that's in there I know right
what a fun gift I got some uh Wizarding
World related socks too
and then we also have uh oh I didn't
bring them in here I have some Harry
Potter Pez as well
oh yeah yeah all the likes too yeah
thank you guys we will uh we'll get the
Harry Potter wizard quote before we go
to James what's up James
thank you for subscribing to the channel
so I'm confident this unboxing will not
take as long as our God of War Ragnarok
Collector's Edition Unboxing which uh
took a while
that had a lot of stuff in it
yeah so what is this I think this is
officially yeah this is officially
licensed
Wizarding World WB
oh and he also has this little uh
Hogwarts Castle sold separately
see that right there
P.O box dude Logan I need to get a P.O
box I'm getting more people who are
wanting to send me stuff
I need to set up a P.O box oh no I broke
the Box
oh well
oh well
foreign
there we go so they're in a nice little
tray
so we got that as I like I hold it to
the mic like you guys like the mic is
the camera
all right and they're in this little
tray here
oh man look at them
okay oh man we might need some scissors
let's see
oh I don't think we're gonna be able to
get them out right now individually
oh wait no they just pop off pretty
easily we're good we're good we're good
all right Hagrid
come on out Hagrid
get that nice little that nice little
crunch in there
all right Hagrid is free
there he is
look at our dude agrid
rubius Hagrid keeper of keys and games
at Hogwarts there you go there's your
impression
all right hold on let's see
but Haggard right
put him right
right there for now
all right then we've got a little book
wow that is super tiny we could put that
in Hermione's hand though the little
book
then we got the Sorting Hat right here
come on Sorting Hat oh foreign
that one just launched across the room
difficult very difficult
no Hagrid fell over
[Music]
there you go Hagrid
oh my gosh little Hedwig
it's gonna make me sad
not Hedwig oh dude this one is in there
hold on Hedwig is definitely gonna go
see if we can get this on
Oh I thought hey we was going to get
launched she actually did not get
launched
[Music]
here's Hedwig
[Music]
all right and dude this letter looks
almost exactly like our
[Music]
wait till I hold this letter up it looks
almost exactly like the little emoji
that we have
which obviously that's what it's based
on but oh dude it's super tiny but
there we go get the nice little focus on
it there
[Music]
I know guys rip it's a Hedwig
oh and here's our good boy Fang
yeah that emoji there we go
look at Fang
Fang the boar Hound
and then we've got the trio
all right so their legs are really thin
so I want to be careful that I don't
I don't break the little thin legs here
all right so we got Ron first because
Ron Ron doesn't get enough love dude
doesn't get enough love
there he is
so like a very different art style you
know not clearly not based on
the movie characters
[Music]
all right we got Hermione next
I can't do not they are just they are in
this plastic so
tightly
oh Hermes might be my favorite
just love this like the style of this
there we go now let's see if she can
hold the book
her hand is super tiny
oh maybe
nope it was a good thought
it was a good thought
[Music]
and then last but certainly not least
the boy
who lived
boy who lived himself oh dude I didn't
even realize they're like
they're posable
oh no way
yes like you can like turn as you can
like up and down a little bit
[Music]
and I think Harry might actually be able
to uh
so wait what's the point of the letter
if they can't actually hold it
[Music]
Potter
can't even go to a Bookshop without
making the front page
there you go you just get the organic
you got two organic you got three
organic Impressions tonight
[Music]
come on Harry
all right we'll have to arrange them
later I might they might look cool
right there
Potter
can't even go to a Bookshop without
making the front page
all the Sorting Hat
oh yeah we could put the Sorting Hat on
one of them right
[Music]
okay he's propped up for now
you gotta get like if you're gonna do
the malfo impression just like go go to
the mirror and before you say Potter you
just have to like
you just like scrunch your face up like
this you know
[Music]
Potter
it's probably destroying this mic right
now by the way my apologies
all right so whenever we hit 100 likes
we also
like to do
a random bit of quote trivia from the
Harry Potter series
so this one always takes me a second so
Talk Amongst yourself chat what do you
guys have going on lately
anything fun happening any any good
games coming out soon
any good games coming out that we we
would like to uh talk about
[Music]
all right I got the book I've selected
the book
now we need to pick a
chapter
wow okay this almost never happens I
think I turned right to a good one
all right so if you're new here this is
the Harry Potter quote challenge I'm
going to quote a line from the English
us version of Harry Potter
I almost I almost said the name of which
book this is not going to give you the
name of the book though so first you
guess which character you think that
said it and then try and guess the
correct book as well you get two points
that you can spend on
I don't know you can uh you were Garner
great admiration from your peers here at
house Dragon tour
yeah this there's a lot of good games
coming out this year for sure all right
here's the quote
[Music]
turn down our music just a bit
okay chat here it is here it is here it
is
all those times we were in that bathroom
and she was just three toilets away said
blank and we could have asked her
and now
dot dot dot
all right here's the here it is again
all those times we were in that bathroom
and she was just three toilets away
said blank
and we could we could have asked her and
now dot dot dot
all right character and book character
in book
I don't know how I turned immediately to
one that I was like oh this is a good I
think this is a fun one
all right let's see let's see let's see
who we got two points down let's try a
tour yeah Ron Chamber of Secrets Ron
book Ron chamber Secrets two book two
Ron Ron probably Ron Shavers oh my gosh
was that one that was way too easy
that was way too easy okay I do see a
couple Ron haploid prints Ron Deathly
Hallows nah it was chamber
it was chamber can't type fast enough
Ginny
it has to be Deathly Hallows no Mr Moe
no no no no yeah it's chamber's secret
so it is the very first
it's actually the very first line of
chapter 16.
Chamber of Secrets
yeah all those times we were in that
bathroom and she was just three toilets
away said Ron bitterly at breakfast next
day and we could have asked her and now
it had been hard enough trying to look
for spiders escaping their teachers long
enough to sneak into a girl's bathroom
the girl's bathroom moreover right next
to the scene of the first attack was
going to be almost impossible
yeah
yep Chamber of Secrets
enemies of the air beware
enemies of the air beware
oh man fine I'll make it harder next
week make it harder guys
people I mean people usually get it
fairly quickly
but never that
never that many that fast that was good
that was good you guys nailed it
all right so did somebody say is it
seriously two streams left
no freaking way
so today is
the 17th
oh my gosh you're right
so we got next week the 24th
then we got the 31st then
we're single we're single digits man
single digit streams
what
[Music]
is insane dude it is insane
oh all right so let's preview things I
keep saying I'm gonna finalize details
I just need to set the time really we're
definitely going to do a countdown
stream like Monday afternoon leading up
to the midnight launch which I just
realized a couple streams ago now I have
to buy yet another copy
because the hard copy I ordered won't be
here
oh that's annoying
um
but yeah so we'll do a countdown stream
and then I'm gonna live stream the game
for a while which I feel like most of
you aren't going to be watching I know
some of you have said you will because
you're you're
gonna be playing on last gen so you
don't mind you just want to know you
want to go ahead and watch and see what
the game's like
I'm still trying to decide if we're
going to be on Twitch or YouTube for the
gameplay stream we're definitely going
to be here for the countdown
I've been like weighing the pros and
cons all week of both
and we did a big poll on Twitter and
most everybody voted for it was like 70
30 in favor of YouTube
won't be watching I know right yeah I
I get the vast majority are not going to
be watching
I get the vast majority aren't going to
be watching
Gabe so I'm a twitch affiliate so it
won't twitch doesn't allow you to
co-stream at the same time if you're a
twitch affiliate
[Music]
yeah YouTube is nice to have the vods
you might be playing really Jenny you
might be playing
oh dude it's gonna be it's gonna be fun
time man fun times so yeah this week I'm
trying to think of the big Hogwarts
Legacy videos I have left so I want to
do one more big story video
I was hoping to have it ready by
tomorrow
but I don't think it's gonna be ready by
tomorrow
it's gonna be I want to take all that
we've learned from the character cards
and sort of make it as a follow-up to my
previous lore video like a what we know
about the lore and the story
so that's going to be one
then
probably a couple more I need to bring
over my order of the Phoenix let's play
from twitch
and gotta decide like what I want the
other videos to be
because that gives us like two weeks
right
yeah
oh my gosh man
yeah some people could do that EFA
Spartan and I mean it's like everybody's
different you know So for anybody who
wants to hang out and watch I will be
live streaming somewhere
somewhere I will be live streaming it
any other voice actors revealed yet know
just those that they've uh
there might be a couple on the IMDb page
that we had known about from a while
back
but as far as like official
announcements yeah
I don't know Clancy I was off work
Monday so that's why I did so many
streams Monday
but now I'm back to work so
they'll probably be in the evening at
some point
[Music]
yeah that's Nick we're going to be doing
like uh so in the countdown what we're
gonna do is
I can't go back and watch all my old
videos but we're gonna go back and look
at a lot of old stuff and just like
talk about how far we've come all that
sort of thing
no Thomas I don't I need to I mean well
this so This stream right here is every
Tuesday night that one is set the other
one I don't because I work full time
and so I'm there pretty much during the
day like a regular nine to five
[Music]
but who knows who knows that may not be
that may not be forever it may not be
forever man I'd love to have like a
regular streaming schedule and stream
multiple times a week
on either twitch and or YouTube yeah
react react to yourself video I know
right going back we did a little bit of
that a couple streams ago and was like
oh my gosh some of these were bad
uh let's see I think James subscribed to
the channel That was 18 minutes ago de
beaves Junior subscribed thank you so
much
thank you very much
do I know all the spells in the game
I don't think we know all of them
but we know the vast majority yeah we
know the vast majority of them
[Music]
okay so
um yeah man we've been going two and a
half
hours
um like I said the lore Story video is
going to be the next one from me
I'm hoping to get it out by the end of
the week but those those take a little
bit longer so we shall see we shall see
oh wait we gotta put our house wrecking
tour Hammer back
but thank you all so much for being here
man these streams are an absolute blast
we've been having more and more people
showing up each week
I don't even know how many we had at one
point I think we were I think we were
over 500 people in here at one point
which is just amazing man amazing
so yeah if you guys want to continue the
conversation exclamation point Discord
for those of you who aren't already in
there Nico tells me we're very close to
becoming a Discord
oh gosh I forgot what is it Nico what's
the official
we're very close to unlocking something
cool in the Discord
you could tell I don't I'm not like
I post in Discord occasionally but I'm
still
a verified Discord there you go you know
I hear it's a big deal
here it's a big deal
I actually don't know what all it means
but Nico and elwin in the mods
Christy Tim like
Dylan they they
tell me what's good in the Discord
but yeah a lot of people there hanging
out we do have a spoiler section so I
know some people do like talking
spoilers so you can go there to talk
spoilers
indeed radio glad you had a good time
glad you had had a good time all right
guys I hope you all have a fantastic
rest of your week be good to each other
keep each other Safe Keep faith and I
will talk to you again very soon
later guys have a good one
[Music]